chocolate or vanilla chocolate all the
way
i don't even understand vanilla vanilla
is just sort of a disappointing
chocolate
wow racist much
[Applause]
all right joe biden may have discovered
the secret to time travel
hear me out we're currently seeing the
middle east unravel
faster than ilhan omar's marriage to her
brother
we're seeing inflation roaring back like
that rash cat got at coachella we are
seeing absurd gas prices
and a gas shortage we're at the mercy of
criminals trying to shut down a pipeline
and a president who actually did shut
one down and speaking of
we have a bumbling leader who scares no
one except young women who use herbal
essence shampoo
oh he'll send a stern letter to our
adversaries as long as it's before his
4pm bedtime
unemployment's rising as benefits keep
flowing crime is back and bloodier than
ever we're witnessing
shootings and murders like never before
well not exactly never before we have
seen it before
in fact we've seen it all before it's
called
the 70s
soon we'll be making another run
don't you leave home without a gun
you could try to escape but sorry
there's no gas
[Music]
and inflation will leave you
broke on your ass oh no
let's go the 70s
yes we are going to hell
the 70s
should have voted for trump oh well hey
the seventies oh no ow
please god no
you don't have to clap that was no
jack jones but it's true we've gone back
to the 70s a 10-year span
so awful we had to create the 80s and
the 90s to erase it
on the plus side if this continues we
might get another one of these
yeah remember that that was the 70s but
maybe we have
yes seriously she is this generation's
farrah fawcett
or maybe jacqueline smith i can't make
up my mind but why should i
she didn't until a few years ago and by
the way it's not like i'm
stalking you caitlyn okay you dm'd me
first
and then i figured i should start
working my magic on you and then
she ghosts me and goes on hannity
i get it you're trans and you still date
women whatever
but i feel like i was let on and it kind
of hurts
just like the 70s and just like today
the crime the joblessness the turmoil of
an
unstable world questioning america's
resilience and also
no coincidence joe biden's in dc
fact is we're learning a harsh lesson
here that progress and stability and
success is just
one liberal away from disaster just one
liberal away
think about that everything great about
america can be unraveled by one leftist
with some power and a vendetta against
america and we have an administration
crawling with them
now take new york rudy giuliani took a
city rife with rampant crime and
hopelessness and turned it into the
number one
global tourist attraction and then
bloomberg inherited it
and didn't screw it up totally but then
this ghoul came along
a vile groundhog murdering idiot so
clueless to human motivation that he
might actually be from another planet
i think they call it saturn he's like a
giant lumbering frankenstein made up of
parts from lesser idiots
and it took only one card-carrying
anti-american comedy to drag the city
back down to its worst
two if you count his wife so now we have
gotham city but minus the batman
but it's not just nyc it's every city
run by dems
and now it's america joe biden was so
nostalgic for those years when he had
real hair
that he took us back there in a matter
of months
it's a pattern republicans create the
bank account that the democrats end up
blowing like
hunter's backup eight ball
saddled with the attention span of fruit
flies high on frank with
iqs lower than cnn's ratings libsy the
progress made by republicans as
wrong and therefore an opportunity
opportunity to experiment
and we are their guinea pigs our jobs
our health care our education system
and it's those experiments that lead to
the devastation it's a cycle
liberals like spoiled children ruin
things which republicans like patient
parents
fix and that creates a false sense of
security
that allows liberals to return and ruin
them again
i say we put them up for adoption so we
can have nice things in the house again
i wonder what the angry white male
[Music]
thinks
it's like the america i grew up in urban
decay
crime inflation gas lines
democrats
you make me feel young again
so can we time travel out of this mess
maybe if we didn't have so many options
for entertainment back in the 70s we had
three channels and two restaurants that
delivered
one was chinese and the other one was
chinese
we had almost no options for pornography
unless you count the sexy indian girl on
the lando lakes box
sometimes we got creative and we went to
work on the sears catalog with an eraser
nobody understands that we had no choice
but to save ourselves but now it's
different we have netflix and hulu there
are 407 espn
channels amazon delivers and so does
your dealer cat
the criminalized pot keeps us ambivalent
and china and disney plus
keeps us distracted the whole world
outside could crumble
but we're too happy binge watching the
crown the question is
for how long well thank god i still have
this
[Laughter]
don't worry i laminated it
[Applause]
welcome tonight's guest
he's so country he thinks a seven course
meal is a possum and a six-pack
country music singer and songwriter
larry gatlin
when he tells a joke the woke shall
choke
host of the nick apollo show podcast
comedian nick apollo
stand up comic who needs a booster seat
writer and comedian joe devito
[Applause]
and she said till death to his part and
now her husband's missing
[Applause]
fox news contributor cat tiff
all right i'm excited larry i got three
questions for you
one do you remember the 70s two do you
even remember jimmy
carter and three do you remember doing
coke in the carter white house
i thought tonight was going to be a
career move to me i don't i don't think
it really turned out that way
well you know the old deal but if you
remember the 70s you weren't part of
them you know that's the standard
what was the second question the second
you just answered it uh jimmy carr
jimmy carter we were friends he was a
nice man
in my opinion if anyone was ever
you know not really up to the task
of that that that would be if you're
gonna like put it in the dictionary and
you know illustrate it uh good man
policy's all wrong
um and do i remember snorting coke in
the white house you know i have
i have kids and grandkids who watch this
show
uh about so you're saying that they all
remember
no but hey it just seemed like the thing
to do
i mean what the hell well i had some
help from
just they understand anyway steven
stills i didn't say that
i didn't say i didn't say that i didn't
say that i could get sued
no look you even still's son
yes yes that is the most insidious drug
on the planet mm-hmm uh i gotta disagree
well let me let me give you the this the
test they would put little monkeys in
the cage
and the little monkeys that tell to
teach them to self-induce they'd bounce
up against this needle and shoot them
and so uh little guy monkeys if given
the choice
to get uh next to a little girl monkey
or to get the cocaine
which one do you think they took well
what's it caitlyn jenner oh
no they they took the the cocaine every
time
it's insidious yeah but those monkeys
were in a band right
they just they ran out you know so it it
was
it was crazy and like i said it just
seemed like the thing to do
the 70s and so stephen and i mean nobody
was down there i mean so we just
went in there in the library restaurant
well you know what
nick this is good news for everybody
because if we're going to go back to the
70s that means we're all doing coke in
the white house
yes apparently i did it with obama i got
to be honest
it wasn't a white house it was a holiday
inn right
loudon county or something like that
what do you so it's only been a hundred
and some odd days nick and they're all
going to hell
everything's going to hell in a handful
is that a surprise i mean trump said
everything called everything that we're
going through right now yeah
i want to yell at people who voted for
um biden but we really know nobody did
so i can't find it
but um allegedly here's the thing yeah
that's my opinion not foxes
me and al roker um but here's the thing
you know jimmy carter like he said i got
i met him on the tonight show nice guy
but he
he was a horrible politician right right
he but
biden is inflicting this pain
intentionally that's the difference
yes am i and it's not even biden we keep
saying biden we know it's aoc and bernie
and the rest of the idiot so yeah yeah
yeah
right yeah you know he's a hollow vessel
he doesn't like if they if
if he doesn't do what they say they
don't give him the pudding
that's true i just want to go to bed
by putting what are your thoughts on
this
theory that we are returning to the era
known as the 70s you were grew up in the
70s right
a little bit yeah i thought some of it
yeah yeah you're about 60 now
about yeah i was very coked up as a
child
yeah it's definitely it's definitely
that 70s joe that's what we have with
biden
yeah and that it you know it really
feels like a throwback too because we're
saying things like
are you is jenner gonna run yeah
i know you were sick earlier so yeah i
mean if i if i worked in the u.s embassy
somewhere i would pack a bag
yeah because things are going to get bad
um and it's it's unfortunate you look at
somebody like
they they don't seem to understand that
their policies that are bad have bad
consequences it seems to baffle them all
the time and then you see
de blasio and his wife on new year's eve
dancing in an empty time square like
it's i am legend
right there they're having this
wonderful time meanwhile she put her in
charge of a
charity that has 800 million dollars
unaccounted for
exactly now if that's not the ultimate
leftist program right there
the money went in and nothing came out
at the end yeah i don't even think larry
could spend all that on
coke i tried i tried
and then i borrowed some of steel's
money he's got a lot more than i did
that has to be a three-day weekend so
kat
i i talked about the trade-off before
the election which is people were
willing to vote trump out of
office for his mean tweets and so what
you got in exchange
and that worked i mean they got no more
mean tweets but now you've got inflation
you got unemployment you got a middle
east so it's like now all the news
anchors can sleep better at night
because trump doesn't hurt their
feelings but the rest of us are all
screwed well the news anchors are
complicit and all this you know the
government's saying hey it's no big deal
like the gas thing for example hey
don't panic it's no big deal how is not
being able to leave your house not a big
deal
yeah and this is why people were
concerned you know pete buddha judge
might not have this one
but with all those crisis of this
magnitude that he had to face as the
mayor of south bend indiana yes
but it's all identity politics and now
people don't have gas and they're stuck
at home and they can't go to work but
then they just you know they get the
government payments
and they stay home and the the
environment's not affected if they need
food the government can bring it to them
so maybe it's not a problem if you view
the world a certain way where
individuals aren't responsible for
taking care of themselves
well i'm always responsible for taking
care of yourself i hear no you don't
yeah i do don't bother you excellent i'm
married
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else